[Music]
on this wednesday night putin's latest
threat his warning to the west to keep
out of the way or face the consequences
as he halts gas supplies to two
neighbors plus a ukrainian peace
negotiator tells me why he keeps trying
this is
extremely hard
anguish for canadian veterans who served
in afghanistan and then
i regretted what i had done and their
heartache for those left behind
medical mystery the surge in children
with acute liver disease the symptoms to
watch for
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
russia's president is issuing new
threats and cutting off gas supplies to
neighboring countries as western
countries appear more emboldened and are
giving ukraine more lethal weapons to
defend itself shipments of russian gas
to poland and bulgaria both nato members
have stopped and vladimir putin warned
western countries today to back off
they should know putin told lawmakers in
saint petersburg that our retaliatory
strikes will be lightning fast anyone he
said who sets out to intervene in events
from the outside and creates
unacceptable threats for russia will be
hit with a quick fire military response
we have all the tools for this he claims
that no one else can boast of having
in ukraine there are reports of a
tentative agreement to create safe
passage for some of the hundreds
believed to be sheltering in the
besieged city of mary opal ukrainian
forces in that port city's massive steel
plant are still said to be holding out
their situation rapidly deteriorating
redmond shannon has our top story
tonight
ukrainian rockets again fired at enemy
targets in the donbass on a day when
kiev confirmed russia had made more
gains in the east of the country
and as a ukrainian commander pleads for
a dunkirk style evacuation for troops
and civilians holed up inside mariupol's
as of style steel works
moscow meanwhile says there were
explosions just inside the russian
border again including at an arms depot
in peaceful warsaw the tentacles of this
conflict were felt too russia halting
natural gas exports to poland and fellow
nato member bulgaria because their gas
payments were not made in rubles
polish prime minister matteos
morovietsky says his country is prepared
with strong reserves built up but
bulgaria is scrambling both countries
seeking to stop relying on russian gas
by the end of the year is another
provocation from the kremlin
but it comes as no surprise
that the kremlin uses fossil fuels to
try to blackmail us european commission
president ursula van der lion says
paying in rubles would breach sanctions
hungary is already doing it a victory of
sorts for vladimir putin now instigating
a gas war to sow division within the
west for me
germany's economic minister insists it
will not pay in rubles but the
industrial giant is hugely dependent on
russian gas with few alternatives in
place this is the shocking fact germany
is one of the most unprepared countries
within the european union and it's
almost inexplicable either from a market
or a political perspective germany's
energy vulnerability a factor in its
delayed decision to send heavy weapons
to ukraine we have to admit we are
facing war and the war is
beyond the war that is raging in ukraine
some experts say germany could face a
significant recession if the gas supply
ceases but at least for now the cost of
this war in the west remains a purely
economic one redmond shannon global news
london
the house recognized that the russian
federation is committing acts of
genocide against the ukrainian people
canadian mps have voted unanimously to
back an ndp motion calling russia's
attacks in ukraine a genocide it states
there is clear evidence of massive war
crimes taking place the motion though is
not binding and does not carry direct
consequences under broader international
law canada's foreign affairs minister
today announced sanctions on more than
200 people loyal to vladimir putin and
said ottawa is working to reopen its
embassy in ukraine in the coming days
a little later i speak with a ukrainian
mp who is part of the delegation
negotiating with russia while russian
troops attack his country he explains
how difficult that is and why he's doing
it
but first questions about a holiday
prime minister justin trudeau took in
2016 have resurfaced the federal
conservatives want the rcmp to reopen an
investigation into the trip trudeau and
his family took to the bahamas they were
guests of the agakhan the federal ethics
commissioner ruled that breached
conflict of interest rules because the
aga khan's charity had received federal
money well now the conservatives have
documents they claim warrant a fresh
police investigation our chief political
correspondent david aiken explains
donna the documents the conservatives
received include a long analysis rcmp
investigators completed to determine if
prime minister justin trudeau should
face a criminal fraud charge
in the house yesterday the prime
minister gave the rcmp the missing clue
they need to begin a formal
investigation into defrauding the
government the rcmp documents explain
that an individual who is a government
official who receives a gift from
someone who has business dealings with
the government and if that official
fails to get permission from a
supervisor then a fraud has occurred
after a long investigation the rcmp
concluded that trudeau was a government
official that his vacation on the
ogacon's private island was a gift and
that the occacons foundation was an
organization that had business dealings
with the government but did trudeau get
written permission from anyone to take
the trip at the time the rcmp said that
was unknown after all since the prime
minister is the head of government who
would have had the authority to give him
permission the rcmp never interviewed
trudeau at the time and so no criminal
charges were ever laid
but then on tuesday did the prime
minister give himself permission to get
away with committing a criminal fraud
offense
no mr speaker the conservatives now say
if the rcmp had had that answer back in
2017 that no he did not have written
permission that information might have
led to a fraud charge this is very
serious mr speaker this is a big deal
the prime minister of canada has
potentially committed criminal offenses
the ethics commissioner rule trudeau did
break ethics laws four violations in
fact of the conflict of interest act but
trudeau now dismisses the tory's
concerns as political theater it's clear
that the conservative party has run out
of ideas and material when they choose
to raise issues that were brought up by
the conservative leader
three conservative leaders ago as for
the rcmp well it repeated today what it
said when it finished its investigation
in 2019 which is it could not
productively pursue a viable criminal
investigation donna all right david
aiken in ottawa thanks the federal
government is streamlining the
immigration process to help resettle
ukrainian refugees but the fate of
thousands of afghan refugees still hangs
in the balance during the last federal
election campaign prime minister justin
trudeau promised to bring forty thousand
afghan refugees to canada about eleven
thousand have arrived
the prime minister blames the taliban
though as jeff semple reports canadian
veterans say the government needs to do
more
this reunion is 14 years in the making
canadian tim laidler served in
afghanistan alongside his interpreter
samander passoon when the taliban took
control last summer laidler helped
passoon's family escape and start a new
life in canada
we have food
and our kids can go to school peacefully
for the past nine months laidler's
charity has helped to evacuate more than
two thousand afghans who supported
canada's military mission but that
lifeline is about to be cut short and
it's just a bureaucratic nightmare for a
lot of these families as of may 2nd
their evacuation campaign will end the
biggest barrier he says isn't the
taliban it's ottawa
with canada's embassy in kabul closed
indefinitely afghans must first escape
to a third country before booking a
flight to canada but neighboring nations
are reluctant to let them in
he promised us that he'll take us even
veterans who fought the taliban now
believe it's time for canada to
recognize the regime and reopen our
embassy i certainly think it's worth it
let's do some sort of recognition get
our embassies reopened and then at least
we can support the tens of thousands of
people we've promised to place here in
canada don't forget us we're protecting
the identity of this afghan father
because he worked for the canadian
military and is approved to come to
canada he's been trying unsuccessfully
for months to get a visa for pakistan
he's afraid to leave his home and
struggling to feed his family we now we
really need their help to help us he
used to work in kandahar at camp nathan
smith along with canadian veteran dave
ward global news first interviewed the
retired sergeant back in november he
spent two decades with the military and
described how difficult it was to watch
afghanistan fall but we had no idea just
how painful until christmas eve when
ward put a gun to his head and pulled
the trigger
and then
i recommend i regretted what i had done
the bullet tore through his jaw cheek
and forehead
but incredibly he survived
i'm very happy in their life
he's now finding refuge in music friends
and his faith
but says the trauma from his tour in
afghanistan is compounded by
helplessness and fear for those left
behind it's so hard because i
ready that wants to go and help
innocent lives you know it doesn't get
utilized and just watching everything
then
it's hard then it's a very common
struggle for a lot of veterans their
evacuation is over laidler's charity is
now returning to its original focus
supporting veterans mental health
and these days demand for their services
is overwhelming
jeff semple global news st catharines
ontario
troubling trend coming up what we're
learning about a mysterious acute liver
disease in children
scientists are working hard to determine
what's causing acute liver disease in
some children including here in canada
data from the world health organization
shows at least 190 cases of severe liver
disease have been identified in 11
countries the largest number of cases
are in the uk but there are some reports
of children in canada also falling ill
jamie morocco explains how it's
affecting kids and what researchers are
watching for
as families continue to try to steer
clear of coven 19 world health officials
are now also tracking a mystery illness
causing hepatitis in kids the majority
have diarrhea and vomiting
and few days to a few weeks later they
start developing the main symptom is
jaundice so their skin starts to turn
yellow one child has died officials
haven't confirmed where and 17 others
have required liver transplants what's
missing is the cause doctors in alabama
treated a cluster of nine severe cases
each one of them tested positive for for
adenovirus that's a common virus that
can leave kids with a range of flu and
cold like symptoms some experts worry
increased pandemic isolation has left
kids with overactive immune responses to
typical childhood illnesses others
wonder if covet 19 could play a more
direct role it's certainly a possibility
but it's premature to put a stamp on
that links to the coven 19 vaccines have
been ruled out none of the children in
the uk where this was first reported and
were the no most number of cases have
been reported none of them had received
the covet 19 vaccine canadian officials
aren't revealing much about the cases
here including how many they are
investigating where they are located and
whether they are linked to the
infections abroad the world health
organization says it expects more cases
will emerge and with so many unanswered
questions surveillance is now a priority
jamie morocco global news toronto
is it possible to negotiate with a man
like vladimir putin it is hard
ahead insight from a ukrainian mp trying
to negotiate peace
[Music]
imagine you are part of the ukrainian
team negotiating with russia when russia
is attacking your country and killing
your people that's what rustam umarov is
doing he's a ukrainian mp and he's part
of the delegation holding peace talks
with russia he along with russian
billionaire roman abramovich suffered
symptoms of suspected poisoning earlier
this month after a meeting in kiev
i spoke to him earlier today from a
location he preferred not to disclose
mr umarov thank you so much for taking
time with us i know that ukraine wants
this war to end of course the whole
world does everyone wants peace but
after more than two months of an
invasion of terrible aggression attacks
on civilians there's still no sign of
peace so do you have hope
well uh we always have hope
we wanted
the world to know that
even though we are protecting the
european security the global security
we're able to negotiate for the peace
because we understand that
this war can bring
more bloodshed
to the region
how do you sit at a table and have peace
talks
with the russian side when so many
ukrainians are being killed this is uh
extremely hard
emotionally
physically
but because we know that if it will
continue it will kill more people
we uh assume that we are
uh wartime
peace and voice so that is why we have
to take it
into consideration that if we don't sit
we don't
negotiate we don't find a solution
it will continue
so that is why we have to take it
serious and
we take it as our
job is it possible to negotiate with a
man like vladimir putin i know you're
not in the room with him but he is most
definitely in charge
it is hard
because
he tries to open up several verticals
which means that
legally when you negotiate with
on one topic
you constantly
are fighting back in the field
in addition uh he goes and fights you in
the media
so basically there are up to five six
different dimensions that you have to
fight
the decision is only in his head
so the only person who can stop this
bloodshed is vladimir putin the west is
of course providing more lethal weapons
more every day the rhetoric too is
ramping up the us defense secretary says
he wants russia weakened russia's
foreign minister says the west is waging
a proxy war against russia and warns of
provoking world war iii
what do you read into all that and how
worried should the world be
well the world should definitely be
worried why because the war already
started so
every person who is not involved at this
stage should be
uh
should be thinking that it helps than
russia if it is not involved in
finishing the war on the
supply side we appreciate
canada's support for half a billion
support they provided and now they will
be providing
some
apc armored vehicles
uh we appreciate it
do you think that canada has done enough
and has acted fast enough canada is
active uh canada is helping
diplomatically politically nevertheless
the
speed is extremely important so we need
to supply as much equipment as we can
otherwise
this may uh
become a beginning of third world war
is there a line that russia crosses
where you say okay we're done we're not
talking anymore
no there are of course uh red lines that
we are not going to cross which means
that
our president told that if people in
mariupol azov style still planned
will be killed
uh this is a red line for us which means
that we will be exiting from
negotiations i would
like to say the whole world that
ukraine
is working on evacuation of their
citizens
of all categories of people
including wounded soldiers
and it is extremely hard
we're trying our
best
uh we're putting all efforts that are in
our hands
and that is the signal to all world that
we will not leave our people
ukrainian peace negotiator and mp rustam
umarov thanks
hockey history scored next the leafs
player joining the greats with a major
milestone
if you're a canadian sports fan you
probably like what you're seeing right
now the blue jays are back in the swing
of things the raptors made it to game
six and last night austin matthews
became the first toronto maple leaf
player to score 60 goals in a season at
a time of year when the hearts of
toronto sports fans are often broken is
there a reason for optimism eric
sorensen explores the eternal question
donna it's an extraordinary moment for
toronto's three major sports franchises
the leafs the raptors and the blue jays
starting last night with the blue jays
they did it again a home run in the
bottom of the ninth inning to tie the
game and one run in the tenth to seal
another heart-stopping victory the jays
for many a genuine favorite to go to the
world series the raptors just keep
surprising and now in the first round of
the playoffs they've put a top contender
philadelphia on notice coming from three
games down with a chance to tie the
series in toronto tomorrow and then
there are the leafs i know this is the
time of year when their hopes are always
dashed
but this year they have something
special and they have someone special
austin matthews the first toronto maple
leaf to score 60 hands so quick and a
rare gift for stick handling checking
and scoring 60 goals in a season were
first scored in the 1970s by phil
esposito than others the 80s the goal
scoring era peaked with the likes of
wayne gretzky and mike bossie in the 90s
12 more times 60 goals were scored but
it became rare just once in the 2000s
once more in 2012 and now 10 years later
austin matthews in this era a remarkable
milestone you just know how hard it is
to score in this league matthews may be
the most valuable player in hockey this
year the you know reception for my
teammates the crowd i mean everything it
just uh you know it just kind of sends
chills down your bones the leafs carry
the heavy burden of past disappointments
all that's not going to really mean much
if the team can't make a deep run into
the stanley cup playoffs if the team is
able to do that then we'll really see
the city catch fire at this moment
spirits are high for their sports teams
in toronto we got the jay's doing pretty
well we got the raps hopefully going to
game seven winning it and then you got
the leagues are gonna win the cup this
year hopefully so you have the blue jays
playing down the street this evening and
the raptors are here tomorrow night and
the leafs on friday night the playoffs
start next week it can't last
can it
donna of course it can eric sorensen in
toronto thanks
that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
here canada is manitoba's white shell
provincial park we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you